général paul aussaresses bonsoir vous
étiez le coordinateur des services de
renseignements à alger en 1957
vous avez participé à des actes de
torture non mais vous avez participé à
des exécutions sommaires oui vous avez
exécuté combien de gens comme je les
vire la journaliste qui m'a interrogé
serre du monde florence baylet j'ai je
jamais exécuté 24 est ce que comme le
capitaine nous avons entendu tout à
l'heure vous avez des remords non
pourquoi
parce que je n'ai procédé de tels actes
que dans le cas de d'individus qui était
reconnu comme ayant participé à des
actes de terrorisme
mais pour autant s l'honneur d'une armée
que d'exécuter que de tortures et non
non non alors vous devriez en avoir des
regrets vous devrez vous dire c'est pas
comme ça qu'on mène la guerre égoutter
nous n'avions pas le choix il y avait et
dans la bataille d'alger un nom il ya un
nombre très considérable d'actes de
terrorisme et d'actes qui a mené la mort
d'innocents de femmes et d'enfants plus
que du militaire et lorsque nous avions
capturé certains auteurs de ces actes eh
bien nous tentions de reconstituer la
filière qui leur avait permis organisé
organisations qui leur avait permis et
d'avoir la possibilité d'accomplir ses
actes les lois de la guerre autorise la
torture d'après vous certes pas alors
pourquoi
et bien parce que les la justice à
l'époque était impuissante
décider du sort de ces auteurs d'actes
de terrorisme à vous exécutiez les gens
très vite donc la justice avait pas le
temps de s'en mêler la justice n'aurait
pas eu le temps
nos études du temps de garder ces gens
emprisonnés mais il aurait fallu des
mois et des mois avant qu'ils puissent
faire l'objet d'une enquête d'abord et
ensuite d'un jugement général d'autres
militaires n'ont pas choisi comme vous
d'exécuter ou de torture est certain je
pense au général de bollardière ils ont
refusé et foncer à portée de jeunes
aussi qui a refusé pourquoi est ce que
vous vous n'avez pas refuser parce que
j'ai été soumis à des conditions je
connaissais très bien
le général de bollardière dont j'avais
été l'adjoint direct en indochine et
c'était un homme que je considérais
comme remarquable alors pourquoi vous
n'avez pas suivi son exemple et parce
que j'étais je n'étais plus sous ses
ordres
j'étais aujourd'hui j'ai des régimes
généraux gravière avait 1 common man à
proximité d'alger mais il n'était pas
impliqué dans la bataille
le général massu n'a pas la même
position que le général bigeard vous
êtes plutôt proche du général massu qui
il faut le reconnaître il faut faut
aller jusqu'à une forme de repentance ou
pas non faut pas léger j'ai je ne suis
pas en faveur d'une forme de repentance
mais pourquoi
et parce que est une forme de repentance
pour des actes criminels ne se justifie
pas autrement dit une forme de réponse
en soi bien sûr est quelque chose de
louable mais lorsque il s'agit d'actes
criminels et bien j'estimais qu'il n'ya
pas lieu d'avoir un cours à une
repentance mais vous pensez qu'on peut
encore quarante ans après plus de
quarante ans après justifier la torture
utilisées par les mythes air france a
justifié mais a constaté le journal de
france version en algérie il ya des
familles de ceux que vous avez exécuté
oui il ya des familles de personnes qui
ont été torturés
oui qu'est ce que vous leur dites
ils me demandent rien n'ont pas jamais à
bombay et si je vous demandais hebinger
si vous disais nous avons un devoir de
mémoire un devoir d'histoire à faire de
retirer
eh ben je leur dirais que oui vous avez
un devoir d'histoire
en ce qui vous concerne personnellement
mais en ce qui me concerne j'ai été dans
des conditions où j'ai eu recours à des
actes que je n'aimais pas et que j'ai
les remplir général un militaire doit
toujours obéir même dès lors qu'il
s'agit d'enfreindre tirait des lois
humaines écoutez les militaires dans la
plupart dans tous les cas dans tous les
cas auquel j'ai été mêlé d'exécutions
sommaires et de juste de sortir que je
n'ai pas exécuté moi même mais que j'ai
approuvé et ben le militaire rendez
compte à sa hiérarchie
vous dites maintenant on aurait pu faire
autrement
si on avait tout le temps oui vous
comprenez donc d'une certaine manière
qu'on puisse torturé en bosnie en
afrique en argentine mais dont je me ce
qui se passe en afrique en bosnie et en
argentine ne me concerne pas ce qui m'a
concernés étaient la bataille d'alger et
je me suis trouvé dans des conditions
qui ne sont pas celles de d'argentine de
bresse millet de et des yeux que doit
faire la france d'après vous essayer de
réparer une certaine manière non alors
il faut passer passer l'épongé sur des
milliers de victimes
à mon avis il faut passer l'épongé et
pas savoir reconnaître l'histoire
je vous ai je vous ai dit que j'avais
été amenés à pratiquer des exécutions
sommaires dans le cas où j'ai eu affaire
à des terroristes coupables d'actes qui
avait amené la mort d'innocents et il
savait tp il faisait l'objet
d'interrogatoires et vous n'avez aucun
regret je n'ai aucun regret si j'ai des
regrets mais je n'ai pas dans leur
mercie génèrent les souvenirs du général
paul aussaresses membre des services
spéciaux pendant la guerre d'algérie
entre 1955 et 1957 ressemblent à des
aveux d'assassins le général ne rechigne
pas en effet à énumérer les exécutions
sommaires et les tortures auxquelles il
a directement participé
déjà au mois de novembre sur ce même
plateau il confiait qu'il n'avait ni
remords ni regrets mais désormais avec
le récit publié de son action en algérie
au-delà de l'émotion des familles des
victimes
la question d'une suite judiciaire se
pose commentaires agnès vahramian des
regrets peut-être mais pas de remords
pour sa 2ème confession paul aussaresses
ancien responsable des renseignements
français en algérie se veut précis sur
les faits avec le sentiment dit-il du
devoir accompli
il cite des noms assume cette fois
jusqu'au bout ce qu'il avait reconnu il
y a 6 mois
quand j'ai exécuté vt c'était beau jour
d'été pv sur les mains des crimes de
sang et du sang sur les mains le général
aussaresses explique qu'il ne pouvait
pas faire autrement face aux attentats
du fln dans son livre le général lev
deux énigmes de la guerre d'algérie la
première celle du suicide supposé d' ali
boumendjel avocats du fln torturé
défenestré sur ordre du général sa
famille découvre 44 ans après la vérité
je suis absolument bouleversée parce que
je déteste ce que j'ai découvert
et surtout de mettre maintenant un
visage sur le tortionnaire de mon mari
et de nombreux algérienne je demande sur
la réhabilitation de mon mari nous
voulons plus entendre parler de suicide
donc la reconnaissance de la torture et
de et de l'assassinât
la deuxième énigme levé par ce livre est
celle de la mort de larbi ben m'hidi
considéré dans son pays comme le jean
moulin algérien pour le sarrès reconnaît
l'avoir empoignée et pendu nous sommes
en 1957 pour la famille ben m'hidi
aujourd'hui il n'y a ni elle ni désir de
vengeance qui doit être jugé ou non
c'est vrai que le débat actuellement
français est d'actualité quand à la
guerre d'algérie
si on français du g20 ce qui me concerne
via la douleur et puis c'est tout de la
douleur et de la pudeur aucune de ces
deux familles ne souhaitent porter
plainte
il faut dire qu'une loi française votée
en 1968 amnistie tous les actes commis
par des militaires pendant la guerre
d'algérie
selon cet avocat spécialiste du droit
international
le général aussaresses ne pourrait donc
être poursuivi que si ces actes sont
qualifiés de crimes contre l'humanité
dans certains cas lorsque les très
graves exactions déportation tortures
exécutions sommaires ont été effectués
dans un espace temps bref de façon très
massive contre des populations civiles
parce qu'elle était musulmane donc
suspecte d'une façon ou d'une autre là
je pense que le tueur de guerre ont
basculé vers le crime contre l'humanité
une procédure serait complexe mais pas
impossible le général aussaresses lui
n'accepte pas lille et à 82 ans d'être
poursuivi par la justice de son pays
[Musique]